ya imágenes que sin duda van a ocupar
portadas en la prensa internacional y lo
vamos a ver ya mismo con Marta Moya la
tenemos en el estudio Marta bienvenida
de nuevo gracias Rosa vamos a hacer un
repaso por las cabeceras tanto del Reino
Unido como de todo el mundo vamos a
empezar con las portadas de la prensa
británica empezamos con El guardián que
ha hecho una transmisión en directo de
toda la jornada y titulada cuando hemos
tomado la captura de su página web el
Rey Carlos III es Coronado después de la
detención de manifestantes
antimonárquicos Y esto es una cosa que
no se ha comentado tanto Durante este
especial Pero ha habido protestas en el
centro de Londres con los lemas ya
clásicos not My King No mi rey y ha
habido detenciones de cinco personas Al
menos en el centro de Londres en
ráfagasquer hemos destacado también la
portada de The Times que titulaba Carlos
III es Coronado Rey un despliegue
absoluto en la cobertura con las mejores
imágenes de la jornada y también los
detalles de los entresijos de la
ceremonia el telegraph titula con esta
imagen ya histórica del Rey Carlos III
el rey y la reina coronados en la abadía
de Westminster y de independen por parte
de los medios británicos más clásicos el
momento culminante de Gran Bretaña
comienza el reinado de Carlos III
y pasemos a ver algunos tabloides
británicos portadas de tabloides
británicos hasta ahora Marta si Santiago
vamos a empezar con el clásico
que titulaba Dios salve al rey ese
clásico got save the king Carlos y
Camila saludan a las multitudes
alrededor de la ruta hacia buckingham
esto pasaba hace unos minutos después
del momento triunfal de la coronación el
Daily mail titulada su gloriosa
coronación el rey recién Rey Coronado
Carlos y Camila son aclamados por una
multitud en buckingham el Daily mirror
titulaba Carlos III oficialmente
Coronado en una histórica ceremonia el
leilitar mucho más chisposo titulaba
coronación gloriosa se pregunta la
ceremonia se vio se volvió incómoda ya
que la corona no encajaba perfectamente
en la cabeza de Carlos III mientras el
Green hacía una aparición estelar Y es
que la bbc en la retransmisión de la
coronación en un momento dado se ha
visto
ese señor con una guadaña y con la cara
totalmente cubierta y ha ido una
explosión en redes sociales de si era la
el Green ripper esta expresión de la
muerte esto lo reflejaba el daistar y
también el metro titulaba Carlos III
Coronado en una ceremonia histórica en
la Bahía de Westminster Marta pasemos
ahora a revisar rápidamente
periódicos de los otros territorios no
del Reino Unido Más allá de Inglaterra
hablamos de gales Escocia y planta del
Norte Así es rosa vamos a empezar con el
belfast Telegram solo Vamos a repasar
titulares Carlos III Coronado en un
momento histórico protagonizado en la
Bahía en la Bahía de Western el Glasgow
Times destaca en su portada que miles de
personas a esta hora ya han firmado el
libro de felicitaciones a los reyes por
su coronación the scottman en Escocia
titulaba Carlos III y Camila son
coronados reyes de en Westminster y el
scotland Herald titulaba el Rey Carlos
III durante una ceremonia histórica y
por otra parte el Wayne el welles online
una cobertura mucho más relajada que los
otros medios que hemos comentado hacía
una cobertura en directo de todo lo que
ha ido sucediendo en esta mañana de
sábado salimos de las fronteras de las
Islas británicas hablemos de territorios
de ultramar de la mancomunidad y también
antiguos territorios del imperio
británico vamos a empezar en India
porque el Times of India también ha
hecho un despliegue grande en su página
web y titulaba el Rey Carlos III y la
reina Camila son coronados formalmente
el Toronto estar en Canadá un titular
sencillo pero al grano Carlos y Camila
coronados de Australia en Australia
Carlos III Coronado en una ceremonia
Sagrada destaca también en su portada al
príncipe Harry que ha sido ya por muchos
medios catalogado como uno de los
invitados más polémicos de la ceremonia
Y por último hemos destacado el Jamaica
cleaner que ya está pensando en su
independencia el próximo año y ella dice
Carlos III Coronado con un Rito
ancestral en un momento incierto Marta y
evidentemente este acontecimiento ha
ocupado las grandes cabeceras
internacionales si Rosa vamos a empezar
con el New York Times hemos destacado su
portada en papel de este sábado que
vemos la foto de los dos Reyes con el
titular poderoso el poder de la corona
el país ha hecho una transmisión en
directo de toda la jornada de la
coronación hemos destacado el último
titular que decía que los reyes ya
habían llegado a buckingham para el
tradicional saludo que veíamos hace unos
minutos Lemon en Francia también ha
hecho una retransmisión en directo y se
preguntaba a sus lectores si tenían
dudas sobre ese legado del imperio
británico Por otra parte hemos destacado
el global Times de China que titulaba en
su portada que tanto la primera dama
china ya han felicitado a Carlos y a
Camila por su coronación Y por último
hemos destacado el post en el que hace
un repaso de los de El rey del Reino
Unido a Ucrania que no se remontan solo
a la invasión rusa sino que se remontan
a más de 40 años atrás incluso cuando
todavía no se había desintegrado la
unión soviética pasemos a América Latina
que dicen los medios de nuestra región
Marta también mucha cobertura en América
Latina vamos a empezar por la Joya de
Sao Paulo que también ha hecho un
directo con todos los eventos de esta
coronación y titulada Carlos III es
Coronado en una ceremonia en Reino Unido
una ceremonia que ha durado algo más de
dos horas además destaca un dato curioso
Y es que desde 1066 39 Monarcas se han
Coronado en la abadía de Westminster
hemos destacado también la nación de
Argentina que titulaba algarabía gente
pegada a la televisión y protestas
ingredientes todo es comunes en esta
ceremonia de sábado el espectador de
Colombia titula Dios salve al rey de
King Carlos III Coronado como soberano
de Reino Unido un día que esperó toda su
vida Eso dice el espectador Y por último
hemos cerrado con El Universal de México
que hace una cobertura mucho más
tranquila que todos los medios que hemos
repasado Durante este especial y solo
hace una transmisión en directo de la
jornada Marta Muchísimas gracias